UFC straw weight champion hey how's it
going good to see you
yes welcome have a seat we're live so
have a seat and you were alive yes and
welcome hi Jim this is Jim Norton he's
far better at pronouncing your name than
I am
I've I've been struggling with it can I
hear uh Yanni and Joe check give me five
she slapped me in the face how close
wasn't painful with the clothes no I
feel good yeah it was good what's the
proper uh on that champion oh you're on
a champion you're a champion
what happened to your uh you're supposed
to have our Karolina whose last name I
cannot say you're fighting her 205
Katarina Kovach kovitch yes it said I'll
be the one she was supposed to come with
you what happened her right I don't know
maybe she's afraid already could be it
could be I don't know yes an option yeah
no I don't know I don't know what
happened I know a few times because we
went to a few different radio stations
but this one is my favorite this one so
far is the best it's nice have you been
here over here before just a small it's
a great moment
yeah why do you like this one the best
so far people say I'm just I'm very fun
to be around as out oh yeah are you it
it yeah not as much not as much and I'll
tell you this you can feel better
nobody's ever said that about him okay
nobody considers him fun no I don't
think he's gonna understand understand
each other's yeah yeah just so we're off
on the same footing you're running out
of people to fight I mean you really I
mean it's like you're just you're
destroying everybody no I'm not that I'm
taking my job and hobby big passion very
serious that's what you consider it a
hobby too yes it was my hobby still a
hobby see the passion but it's my job
what's it like it in in Europe because
the the woman that you're fighting at
UFC 205 in Poland yeah it's also from
Poland is there a big sort of community
of female fighters in Poland where
sequin today is very big component not
so many like top level female fighters
but I'm very happy for me for
enough for for the polish MMA because
we're making history you know we
fighting on the on 205 at Madison Square
Garden it's going to be the first UFC
show in New York it's a big deal for me
for for all of us so I'm happy that to
polish the best female fighters going to
fight at Madison Square Garden this
fight is supposed to happen in Poland
but I feel like I'm international a
champion I'm EFC strong a champion of
the world so I feel like I must give
this fight for for all of you guys so
that's the deal what did you do if I'm
always interested in what fighters did
before they fought what did you do
before you fart breakfast I used yeah
I've seriously do that in progress all
kinds of stuff you know I'm like I'm
very like open person I like to learn i
like to try i like to see some and so I
used to like I used to do climbing and I
used to be a photographer a matter
photographer so this is what I want to
do after I I retired you know I want to
be back to climbing and taking in
pictures would you like taking pictures
of I'm a terrible photographer you are
yeah I'm a good subject we could get
into the fight you know because I like
my I love Instagram I love social media
and I'm kind of okay with that so I'm
very mad at people when they can take
good picture of me you know all pictures
of you yeah only another you know what
do you like photographing myself selfies
no thank you I don't I don't I don't at
all but sometimes I must do this is it
difficult for you to date date I guess
engaged you are engaged yeah so yes it
is hard it is I'm in the relation for
six years six years yes your fighter and
no he used to be a soccer player
football player soccer player in Europe
we call it soccer mm-hmm so yep so an
athlete oh yeah
I said he understand that I must travel
a lot that
that I must spend few weeks outside the
the outside of Poland so yeah is it hard
for him to watch you fight and know he
might come to New York hey he likes it
he loves it he likes to fight yeah so
he's very supportive I wouldn't want to
feel like I dated I'm a comedian I dated
a comedian once and then just watching
her get heckled by someone in the
audience really bothered me so it was
it's hard was hard to watch someone be
aggressive towards somebody that I was
dating I can't imagine watching somebody
fight that you love I'm nice I'm nice
outside the Octagon you know I don't
like myself at all during the fight you
know like yourself doing I don't like to
watch myself with the big boys and yours
you know I like I like to you like you
when you're not fun yeah yeah yeah
because when you're fighting you become
very very aggressive yeah why how does
that like how do you make that switch
when do you make that switch
psychologically it just it's just not
right you know does it happen like as
you're walking just happen the day
before fight week by week it's every day
it's getting more like more and more did
the fight do you become difficult to
deal with like you'd be like oh no I'm
kind of easy person you know mm-hmm are
you conversation because Rhonda said
that when she fights she hasn't liked
any jokes like the morning or like she
just want to fool around she's like guys
you know are you different because I
like to talk I like to hang on with
people I like to like job but I'm
focusing now I'm focused but I like to
be I like to have some people around me
you know you don't like to be by
yourself no okay can you sleep in Juris
for myself why you dangerous yourself
thank you oh well some people are some
people when they're alone like if I'm
alone I'm start going crazy yeah cuz I
just start thinking weird [ __ ] like I'm
not good along or doing voices yeah I do
for whatever I do yeah yeah I just I'm
not good by myself I need company I have
had people around yet can you sleep daya
because we talked to Wonder Boy
yesterday and he said right before the
fight he's in the locker room asleep
like he just kind of sleeps and then
they wake him up and he goes at fights
mmm me not me no no no nothing except
chill a little bit lie down listen to
some music talk to my coach
I'm ready to go you know I put on good
preparations always always always
so yeah what do you listen to I moved to
Florida to Coconut Creek last week no no
music what music oh oh listen I taught
where do you live
I listen I listen to all kinds of like
what kind of thing like I get you to get
you like ready for a fight though
uh-oh when I ran I listen to Adele and
her loss last night
album Adele said yeah I like it yeah
hello's are good songs the only one I
know what hello hello yeah that's a good
song you like that one yeah but this is
difficult to sing on I sing it no no I
said I've seen a bad blue my voice out
what band why would you have a good
singing voice no oh God
well I don't know they're not I prefer
to fight Lindsay are you nervous about
it I mean it's it is a massive stage to
be in the first New York fight no I
don't know if you know but I fought in
Melbourne with Ronda Rousey enemy for
Etihad Stadium more than fifty four or
55,000 people so I like the atmosphere
just before the fight you know you like
it
you're considered the number one pound
pound pound female fighter in the world
above Rhonda and were you shocked when
she got knocked out like that yes yes
but I liked her so much as a I respect
her as an athlete but more as a person
as a female and I want her to be back
does that when you see Ronda doing
everything that she's doing not just
fighting but you know popping up on SNL
and doing movies in a book and blah blah
blah
does that make does that make the wheels
turn in your head I want to start
branching out and doing this other stuff
or do you just focus yes yes I want to
but there is a time for preparations for
the fight and there is a time for media
and all kinds of different stuff you
know right so I'm taking my job very
serious and you know I I want to be more
focused on my fighting career can you
act very good she just did the whole
hairbrush yes that was very good that's
almost shakes
area and we didn't ask we had cowboy
Cerrone was in before we didn't ask him
but he's doing like six episodes of
always Sonic
I believe huh he's actually doing that
was on its page two of the prep sheet so
a lot of the fighters are doing other
gigs yeah she doesn't care
no yeah but she's worried about her huh
no I'm just saying she showed you
shellfish sometimes yeah good but you're
gonna have to be right like it's an
individual story it's not a team thing
yeah it is but at the end not you know
like my coaches physiotherapists like
dietician in earnest other people they
work with me first
for a long time before the fight but
when I step into the Octagon and by
myself just me and my opponent so yeah
when you're fighting and your coaches
are young you can you actually hear what
they're saying yes I can and this is
good this is good and I like it because
they can see more you know so you
actually that would always shown gotta
be embarrassed to people yelling like do
this do that I know I listen I listen
just to my coaches you know not to other
people but you actually can process what
they're saying be like okay like in in
the heat of the moment you can change up
you're like a robot yeah yeah
so I act like a robot we have some game
plan before the fight but you must take
the fight second by second you know but
you must listen to your corner and just
you know take this fight and just keep
on going how long did it take you to
find coaches that you could trust it
because that's a that's a huge amount of
trust
yes it is so I moved to Florida last
week yeah I changed my team my coaches
my head coach is Mikey Brown Mike Brown
I'm training at a American Top Team in
Coconut Creek Mike he was former WEC
champion before UFC both WEC so I have
good people around me and I feel like I
can trust him and the other coaches and
we were here before Florida Paul oh you
came by my hometown Alston yep do you
miss it are you kind of happy to be
somewhere else I miss it but it was my
choice you know my decision to change
something in my
and I'm I want to do more stuff here in
u.s. so that's why I moved and I really
like a United State yeah Florida seems
like a good place if you're gonna come
to the States it's lovely in Florida
warm yeah you know what's cold isn't it
oh yeah sometimes you have a twin sister
yes I don't I wasn't on older and one
older so your twin sister Rashida she's
an icon a counter an accountant
something yeah I wouldn't think okay
what is your family your sisters what do
they think of the fact that you're
becoming this kind of internationally
known person they're happy for me yeah
they were with me in Vegas and they were
they're alive why you don't stay here
you know it's different people trick you
different than in Poland you know
because yes is simply simply the best a
my organization in the world but it's
it's such a big in u.s. you know bigger
than you so they know you much more here
than in Poland yes and not wait like all
kinds of stuff important like lots of
media obligations like I'm like some
brand ambassador a few big big brands in
Poland but yeah do you like I can do
more here do you and your sister are you
twins where you look exactly alike or
yours no no we totally different what
does she look like skinny quiet and what
she stuff did you fight with her a lot
uh like every brother and sister and or
sister and sister yeah I'm always I kill
I I didn't fight a lot growing up no no
I just got bullied yeah yeah you got
beat no sorry yeah you think it'd be
sorry for using your beat up as a child
mmm not at all most fighters have some
kind of a bad experience no me not me
not you just decided you enjoy it yep
well that's rare usually you don't find
people just enjoy the idea of fighting
yeah just like I want to give this a try
yeah yeah totally and certain and Dana
puts you in this thing and you're
becoming huge you have endorsements like
um like Reebok or other people that's on
you because you have a yeah yeah yeah
Samsung Samsung Samsung Poland
and Reebok and the other yeah feel cool
well good luck in in Madison Square
Garden I'm really happy that you're
fighting you're really fun to watch
tickets tickets go on sale on Friday yes
for UFC 205 at Madison Square Garden
which is on November 12th that's when
the show is tickets are on sale Friday
they're gonna sell out very quickly it's
going to be dead the biggest UFC showed
this year yes it might be the biggest
UFC ever with Connor fighting Eddie and
also Weidman Chris Weidman is on is on
the card Cowboys on the card your honor
it's an amazing and Thompson oh that's
right against that tyron woodley for the
machete a welterweight thing don't knock
me [ __ ] cage fighting to the it's an
amazing card so it's gonna sell it's
gonna be very very exciting guys who
must be there we well oh I'm definitely
gonna try to score a free ticket I was
trying to get Dan to give me tickets I
don't like to pay for them you know very
expensive ya know so I guess that's it
for us for the day where'd our show is
done yes thank you for coming by so much
we have